wave-like sustain itself up against the
wall perfectly straight takes a dolphin
that was born oh my gosh there are doors
that open huh what I'm so screwed their
doors of course their doors that are
open it's a debate the best prop ever
mmm I I this will be a test of how much
weight is a fan of your channel oh okay
I just became one of the most hilarious
props that manga Manx has ever beaten
you with oh yeah yeah I haven't seen
that don't I don't no idea what it is I
don't know which one you're talking
about so I will I will I would really
like to see it when you're done well
just kill hit kill mark first so he can
see no don't kill me why would you come
hey where are you mark I'm in the
building let's make a rule that we
should probably be in the building cuz
it's kind of a big map oh I'm I'm no dog
okay no really no rule that right we'll
just go anarchy fine
but wait did run right past me
hi Wade bye Wade like ten seconds ago
you were right now hi Wade bye Wade I
thought I made it easy I'm something
really big sitting out in the open
ha ha ha there's only a few things that
he could be whoa what are you I think I
know what Bob is remember no you see
nothing
ha ha ha oh come on do the forklift
right the forklift now I of the blue
trash game oh I thought you the forklift
cuz I remember Babs would have done that
I think that was someone else that did
it ok I would have done that in two
seconds mark that's it really means ha
ha ha
I just want to see if it works if it
would that's so mean no no no despair is
you know just uh some sort of clue here
you walk by me you wait he's framing you
yeah you walk by bestow buddy done
you're gonna feel like your face got
slammed in it in a door frame
how do you give hints on horrible I
don't know my remote I'm a bottom half
of a metal door yeah I'm a cactus block
wait for what go back the way you came
in the building bottom floor okay he's
downstairs okay we're gonna dark I wanna
see if he can actually see you okay I
could see you but I don't really look I
know who's the frame joke God Bob just
give it away
see I hear what he actually I figured
there's something with doors I'm
thinking painting first I was looking
for I'm just gonna shoot everything
prepare inside or outside wait I'm in
you're in baby
we're so inside inside the inside but
you're going the other door huh come in
this way which building is it even hey
the main building right what I guess
there's only one to be how do i where do
I get in there ah the side doors and
then you can get in through the roof
holy crap there's ladders on the roof
yes they lot I don't nothing about this
map so I don't even know where you guys
are if you're in the right spot this is
a really interesting hiding spot hmm
save it for later Bob you're local whoa
uh where are you not too far where was
he Lizzie yeah he was a little tiny jar
right here
hahaha Oh shooting and missing so I
thought you'd leave oh no that's not how
this game works professionally spawned
in the building yeah persistence is the
cow persistence is the king of
innovation of some persistence is the
owl persistence is the ball I think you
had it mark I think persistence is the
king of innovation is that it I don't
know if that's it I'm pretty sure that I
can I say something that oh god oh god
oh god how do I get up there where are
you I will look I've forgotten oh I
forgot that was a ladder I died
oh there are no props anywhere in here
how do I tell a prop if there are no
props
okay so don't there's tons of problems
but careful yeah you can fall and die oh
my god I can't go up those stairs
anymore haha you're too small
uh-huh uh-huh
wait you're getting closer yo you're
getting colder
oh you get all you're getting colder
you're somehow changing temperature
independent of your own body almost as
if someone is messing with you
where'd he go I can't see him I don't
know where you went I don't trust any of
you
oh I see what you did Bob I don't know
we'll leave you slide w-wait where are
you oh Allah oh oh oh oh oh my clothes
uh I honestly don't know anymore where
the hell did Bob go oh oh oh oh I just
saw I can't jump ha ha ha you didn't see
him
are you doing are you going hell there I
don't think he knows where I am I just
you're gonna stop moving I really don't
think he knows I didn't leave I didn't
leave wait come back come back here yeah
wow this is like good that's some good
maneuvering by the way bye guys
dolly luck you got it down yeah make it
look like an idiot
figure I got it oh that was gonna be ha
ha ha ha that was oh that was fun Oh
hard to do ha ha ha
you were doing so well Bob ahh you over
said that wasn't patient enough ah yeah
it's ok it's alright I had old plan to
be up on the second story and that
stupid Chinese food box can't climb the
stairs I know
I never knew that before I thought it
could but do well all right let's get
that building and show it who's a man my
mark
Bravo upstairs Delta I got you I got you
break AB upstairs D yeah I think I know
what weight is but I'm not gonna say
anything yet because weight is a new
stepdad ha ha I saw that you tossed the
chair off the railing was trying to move
all right I'm upstairs
all right beautiful Bobby you want to
hide in the same spot yeah let's hide
right next to each other yeah whoo can
we fit here come here
whoo hang on nice thing come come in
here Andy uh-oh
let's go go like this Oh can i oh oh I
can't but aah
meow elleny eleme okay okay okay John
you uh-huh can you oh my go to the front
go to the front okay that's what she
said yes
all right now do I look it get in there
do I look appropriate I know okay well I
want to go up on the other desk or
something okay I got you
oh no all right rope rope oh yeah oh
yeah that's good okay do I look okay
yeah you look good you look fine you
look great I can't see what's happening
cuz my face is in the wall but others
gonna guess uh I guess turn around and
look I can't know I go through the
building and then it's just like me I'm
gonna find it
what are you shooting at oh where are
you guys
what do you mean we don't see you yeah I
do it's good not die in the same spot
whoa mr. dodgeball there
did you hear the noise I made wait was
that what tipped you off no you said
desk Oh desk desks yeah the one outside
with nothing on it
yeah oh well he couldn't get on anyway
he wasn't even on the desk you killed
myself
ah so did it was that a tire did you win
that I think I won cuz I was alive how's
it sounding clever buddy
you didn't kill me oh sorry what this is
fun
it is isn't it ha ha ha no I'm dead
serious this is like ridiculously but
for those watching out here this is like
legit smiles I am having a blast all
right now wait and watch the timer go
down thinking I was hunting Oh
oh my god wait ha ha I didn't move oh
the timer uh okay that's not good
that's called squandering your turn wait
Wow get mark hot yeah mark are you in
here no I'm not where are you I'm I'm in
here whoa okay ah oh god damn it
dingus damn flubber pizza ass god dammit
gotten to move yet you're dead god damn
it
Oh aren't you time I fell Bob are you
gonna pull off are you gonna pull this
off no probably not
Bob if you can pull this off I will buy
you ten thousand dollars in silver
sterling silver I'm gonna hold you to
that
oh god please I hurt myself how much
just ten thousand dollars of silver that
it's it's $10,000 I'd say God what about
worth about $10,000 yeah I will I can
quit you I know gold is like 1200 or
1300 an ounce I don't know what silver
is though where are you Bob ha ha ha ha
Bob I'm hittin art I hate to tell you
this but your
kind of sticker I know no no no no no
Brad Brad give up go go go go go
revealing Oh passage I thought I'm away
boy you don't know [ __ ] are too short
to do this it's not possible oh I looked
around that entire place there's nothing
that hides my head awesome I saw by
myself by the way
I saw in it just like the movie is that
addiction don't you